- Hello everyone.
Welcome to another
episode of Unlocking Lily.
It's always been my dream to be a speaker,
where I can inspire people
to do extraordinary things.
A few months ago I decided to
make a life altering decision.
I quit my day job to pursue this full time
and you guys are all coming
along for the ride with me.
Every challenge that I take on
is to help me grow as a speaker.
My challenge this time
is my first corporate gig
with Sage Summit, which is a
two day business conference.
I'll be taking part in the Mentor Lounge,
where people can come in
and book one on one coaching
with me and talk about two specific areas.
The first area is leadership and vision,
and the second one is
attracting and retaining talent.
When Evan surprised me
with this opportunity
to be part of Sage Summit I
was so incredibly excited.
I was like, "Yes, this
is exactly what I want."
I am so so grateful for this opportunity.
And then I started to think,
oh, I actually have to go out there
and be courageous and show up
and answer peoples' questions
and be someone's mentor.
What if I go there and
I sit there by myself
and no one shows up to talk to me?
How am I going to deal
with that rejection?
What if everybody wants to talk to me
and I have nothing to say?
What if people ask me questions
that are way above my head and I
completely make a fool out of myself?
What then?
And then that's when I was like,
no, no, this is ridiculous.
I need to stop thinking like this.
Obviously Evan recommended
me, because he believed
I am qualified and capable to do this.
Amazing, great.
Well what if I let him down?
It's his name on the line here.
He vouched for me.
I have to perform well.
What if I fall flat on
my face and now he feels
like he made a mistake in recommending me?
What do I do then?
That's when I thought about something
that was quite interesting about me.
All my life I never feel that I'm worthy
of the things that happen to me.
I lean into the gratitude a lot.
I'm so grateful for Evan, for
giving me the opportunity.
I'm so grateful for all
of you for supporting me,
but I never give myself credit
that I have worked hard for something,
that I do deserve it and am worthy.
And that's when I thought, you know what
I need to really change
my mindset around it.
Yes, of course I'm new,
and yes I'm very grateful
for all the opportunities
that are coming my way,
and it wouldn't happen unless
Evan was helping me out.
But at the same time,
my intention is pure.
My intention is to add as
much value as possible.
My mission is to help
people become extraordinary.
As long as I keep that in mind
and work really hard to prepare
myself to show up and say,
"Hey, you know, I am
qualified to do this."
And I am ready and prepared
and I've spent the last couple of weeks
really really preparing and
getting ready for this event.
Then if things do kind of go wrong,
which it will, things are never perfect,
I can learn from those mistakes
and I can use this as an experience
as long as I know that my
intention is to help others.
My intention's about the mentees
that are going to be coming in.
It's not about me freaking
out and being panicky.
If I'm panicking, they're
going to be panicking too.
It's my job to stay calm and provide them
with a great experience, and know that
this is why I'm doing
this in the first place.
So when I thought about all of that
it immediately gave me the excitement,
which was great, and also the confidence
to go and continue on and feel great
that I'm not only incredibly lucky
to be given this opportunity,
I also deserve it,
because I've been working
so incredibly hard
towards this goal.
I'm so excited for this.
Good morning everyone.
Today is actually the big day.
It's about 5, 5:15 a.m.
I'm an early morning riser.
This is amazing for me.
This is like the best
time of the day for me,
where I can reflect and start my day right
and see what are the
things that I need to do.
The first thing that I do,
after I get dressed and shower
and everything, is actually
do a walking meditation.
What that is is that I look
at the environment around me
and just focus on that.
For example, if I were just
to look at these trees,
for example, I just focus on the leaves.
I focus on the color.
I don't think about
anything else but that.
So I'm going to do that quickly,
for about five minutes or so
and then I'll see you very soon.
(upbeat music)
I finally ended up in
the exhibition grounds
where the Sage Summit is taking place.
So I'm just following the crowd
and hopefully I'm going to find it.
And whoever's ahead of me,
hopefully they're going
in the right direction,
and then meet up with Evan very very soon.
He's here already; so early.
I got my badge and I see Evan.
This is so weird.
This is so meta.
Look who it is.
- [Evan] It's Lily, she's filming.
Look at this.
Yours says New to Sage, look at that.
- Yeah
- All right.
- Maybe people will be nicer to me.
(laughing)
We're going to head inside soon.
(upbeat music)
I got out of two back to
back mentoring sessions.
I think, overall, it went really well.
People left really happy.
With the first one I feel like
I could have done more
with his limiting beliefs.
I could have dug a little deeper.
Given the situation, I kind of hesitated.
Any time I hesitate I don't end up
following through the way I want.
I still think he left with tons of value,
but he didn't actually
get to the real issue
that he was facing, so I
definitely needed to change that.
And then the second one, I was able to
take the immediate
feedback that I gave myself
and I started asking more
important questions right away,
so that way I could get to
the solution a lot faster.
I think I still could have
gone a little bit faster than I did.
Better, better, but I
could have been faster
and I could have helped him
a lot more with a solution,
and helping his business and how to
create his messaging around
what's important to him,
but in the end, what made me really happy
is he left and he says,
"I'm going to start doing this right now.
"It's going to be this afternoon,
and thank you for helping
me take immediate action",
and that, to me, is the biggest thank you
someone could give me.
So I feel really good.
Tomorrow I'm back at this again
and I'm going to try to find ways
to get to the problem a lot
faster than I have been.
And that's been an
ongoing progress for me.
I'm really excited for
tomorrow, but super pumped
about the two mentees that I had today.
Okay, bye.
Today is day two of Sage Summit.
I was just thinking about
the two mentoring sessions
that I had, this morning and
how much joy that brought me.
I always approach any
kind of mentoring session
or coaching session with
a lot of nervousness,
because I'm always worried that
I'm not adding enough value.
What are the things
that I could do better?
And then once I have
the person face to face,
everything else just kind of fades
and I just focus on them and
the things that they can do
to inspire themselves.
So really thinking about the
two people that I had yesterday
and how happy they were when they left
and how they're going to
take immediate action;
I actually received an
email from one of them
saying that his day went
from a 7 and 1/2 to a 11
and he wanted to thank me for that.
So all of that makes it so worth it
to wake up at 4:45 in the morning
to get down there and to
do the mentoring session.
I don't know, that's why I do what I do.
It's to see other people happy.
It's to see them getting inspired.
It's to see them taking action right away,
whether if it's in their life or business
or relationships, whatever
it is that they need.
And I'm going to just take
that with me this morning.
And I feel a lot less nervous.
I feel way more excited than nervous.
So it's all good.
It's going to be a great day.
It's the last day of the summit,
so it's going to be a fabulous day.
All right, just got out of
the keynote with Rick Mercer.
I'm going to head over
to the mentor lounge.
I think Evan's already
here, so let me go find him.
(dramatic music)
All right, day two of Sage Summit done.
Overall it was a really great experience.
I haven't been to an
accounting conference before,
and who knew that it would
actually be a lot of fun.
There was a keynote with
Rick Mercer this morning.
To be honest, I didn't know who he was.
For those of you who don't know,
he is a Canadian comedian and
his keynote was really good.
Today I didn't have any coaching sessions,
but I used the opportunity
to learn from Evan.
I had some questions for him,
so he guided me through that.
And I was right beside
him, so I was able to
kind of sit in and
eavesdrop, a little bit,
into his sessions and learn from him
and see what he does, so that way
I can use some of that method myself
too and see the way he asked questions,
looking at his thought
process and all of that.
Overall it wasn't' a waste, even though
I was looking forward
to meeting more people.
But every opportunity is
an opportunity to learn
So it was great.
Being part of the Sage Summit
was such an incredible experience for me.
Not only did I get to mentor people,
help them out with their
business and lives,
I got to watch some great speakers
deliver their message to us.
I also met a new friend.
Her name is Rebecca.
She shared her favorite
quote with me, which is--
- Say yes, and figure
the rest out afterwards.
- Which basically sums up
this entire experience for me.
When Evan came with a
challenge, I just said yes.
I had no idea what was expected of me.
I didn't know the details.
I didn't know where I needed to be
at what time, what day, wherever.
I just said yes and it turns out to be
one of the best experiences I've had
in a very long time, and
I'm so glad I said yes.
For my next challenge I'm going to be
bringing all of you behind the scenes
in my mentoring sessions with Evan.
I learned from Tony Robbins
that success leaves clues.
If there's something you really
want to be successful at,
you need to study and mentor under someone
who has been there and has
been successful consistently.
And to me, Evan perfectly embodies that
and is such a great mentor for me.
The question of the day is,
what is that one scary
thing that you said yes too
that turned out to be an
amazing experience for you.
Thank you so much for watching.
Your comments and encouragement
really really gets me excited
and wants me to keep going
and making all these
videos for all of you.
I actually have a special
shout out for Jason Bean.
Jason Bean wrote, "this is so cool."
Honestly Jason, you've
been there since day one
and I'm so incredibly honored
to have you on this journey with me.
Once again, thank you so much guys.
I love you all and I'll
see you very very soon.
(kiss)